With Disney distributing their films all around
the world it is common for them to make changes
with their animated features for different
markets.
Some of these variations might seem insignificant
to us but it could mean a world of difference
to that other country.
Sometimes these modifications are due to events
that happened around the world and Disney
felt an adjustment was needed.
Here is Screen Rant’s list of ten Alternate
Versions of DISNEY Movies You Never Knew Existed.
Remember to click that like button when we
come across a fact you don’t know and stick
around to the end of the video for a Zootopia
story that changes the way you see the movie.
Monsters University
In their dorm Randall Boggs shows Mike Wazowski
a tray full of cupcakes that reads, “Be
my Pal” after he fixes the upside down one.
This joke translated well for English speaking
audiences but what about other countries?
When Disney released the film to foreign countries
that didn’t speak English they changed the
letters to smiley faces.
That way, when one is upside down it just
looks silly and the joke works but in the
US we always want you to be our dal, I mean
pal.
Toy Story 2
When Buzz gives a pep talk to Andy’s toys
before they begin their quest to save Woody
an American flag waves behind him as the American
National Anthem plays and all of this becomes
part of a TV screen.
To help keep the film marketable for foreign
markets the team at Pixar made an alternate
version for foreign distribution.
Instead of a flag they used a globe and they
also removed the National Anthem.
Composer Randy Newman also wrote a new score
called the “One World Anthem” for this
version.
That’s an appropriate name Randy!
Planes
The character Rochelle from Disney’s Planes
is a beautiful gradient of colors from white
to to pink to vibrant red.
Depending on where you saw the film she might
not look the same.
In Australia, she is red, green, yellow, black,
and white with a kangaroo on her side.
She also might not be named Rochelle in China
her name is Yún Yàn Fēi and she has a red,
yellow, and white paint job, while in Germany
she’s white, black, yellow, and red and
referred to as Heidi.
We’ve heard of a horse of a different color
but this is the first time for
a plane.
Wreck-It-Ralph
One of the sugar rush racers in Wreck-It-Ralph
is an Asian themed girl named Minty Zaki and
her name is actually homage to Japan's famous
animator, Hayao Miyazaki.
Since she was already Japanese and a minor
character in the film it is surprising to
find out that she was remodeled for foreign
distribution in Japan.
They even changed her name to Minty Sakura!
We guess the name Minty works for both countries
but not the name Zaki.
Lilo & Stitch
Lilo & Stitch was released in 2002 but the
film was being developed well before then,
the animated hit featured a climatic ending
that involved a plane hijacking.
After the horrific, terrorist events that
took place on September 11, 2001 the filmmakers
rewrote and redrew the ending.
Instead of a passenger-filled Boeing 747 being
hijacked it was replaced with Jumba’s red,
white and blue spaceship.
Originally this climax took place through
the city streets of Hawaii and was also changed
to mountains and volcanoes to avoid undesirable
thoughts during the film.
Inside Out
Making films more relatable to global audiences
seems to always be on the forefront of Disney’s
mind.
When Riley is a baby and she’s disgusted
by broccoli, Anger let’s her dad have it.
Still, dad is no fool; he knows the imaginary
plane will make Riley want her greens and
his work will be accomplished.
But these greens didn’t work for Japan audiences
so the broccoli was changed to green peppers.
Both vegetables gave the chance for Anger
to let off a little steam in either country.
Melody Time
Smoking cigarettes has troubled older Disney
cartoons for many years; Pinocchio hasn’t
been edited because his actions have consequences
but others aren’t as lucky.
The Pecos Bill segment from 1948’s Melody
Time is one of those that have been edited.
Disney digital removed any cigarette that
he was smoking and since most of the film
it just dangles from his mouth it isn’t
noticeable but when he does handle it the
hand movements do look a little odd.
Maybe he’s a magician cowboy practicing
for his next performance.
Moana
In the US the name Moana is quickly becoming
popular with little girls but in Italy a similar
name is popular with grownups, Moana Pozzi.
The woman with the name, Pozzi may have died
in 1994 but she’s still known as one of
the most popular adult film stars in that
country.
Disney changed the name of their 56th animated
feature to Oceania in Italy to not confuse
parents with the adult film star.
Maybe they were afraid that only teenage boys
would be buying tickets.
Zootopia
There is a character in the film Zootopia
named Peter Moosebridge who is appropriately
portrayed by a moose but that’s not the
case in every country.
In Japan he is a Japanese raccoon dog and
in New Zealand he’s a koala named David
Koalabell.
Our favorite variation has to be Brazil where
he is a jaguar named Onçardo Boi Chá.
Even in countries where he is still a moose
they changed his name, in the UK they named
him Moosos Alexander but kept the same design.
It sounds like Peter Moosebridge has identity
issues as he travels around the world.
Frozen
When Disney first developed Frozen, the two
main characters Anna and Elsa were completely
different.
For starters Anna was portrayed as a typical
Disney princess and less strong-minded but
the biggest change came from Elsa.
Elsa was actually the villain of the film,
a hermit with evil powers that was asked by
Anna to freeze her heart after a breakup.
We’re glad that Disney made these changes
and we’re sure they are happy too since
the film is their highest grossing animated
film ever.
What do you think of our video?
Did we skip over any other Alternate Versions
Of Disney Movies You like?
Sound off in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel!
Make sure to click on another Screen Rant
video for more fun lists of your favorite
films and actors!
Thanks for watching!